cette histoire a commencé pour moi il ya
trois ans
je cherchais alors à comprendre comment
areva le champion français du nucléaire
avait basculé dans la rubrique des faits
divers rayons arnaque et soupçons de
corruption je racontais comment areva
avait acheté à prix d'or une obscure
société minière uramin une acquisition
en afrique
devenu un véritable boulet pour les
dirigeants de l'entreprise française
ils viennent de se faire enfler de un
milliard huit la ferme n alors anne
lauvergeon la grande patronne d'areva à
se justifier devant l'assemblée
nationale
en ce qui concerne leurs amis nous avons
acheté trois gisements sujet est tout à
fait tout à fait classique
on a fait des choses plus au losc salins
au delà du rat mine c'est toute la
gestion et l'attitude de madame
lauvergeon qui sont mises en cause
l'elysée envisage son éviction qui sont
s'est posée quand même l'argent très
clairement affiché son refus des
positions qui étaient définis par le
gouvernement
elle finit par perdre la présidence
d'areva en 2011 aujourd'hui l'entreprise
est en quasi faillite est en voie de
démantèlement
en mai dernier le juge van ruymbeke a
entendu pendant plus de dix heures anne
lauvergeon au pôle financier
elle est ressortie avec une double mise
en examen pour faux bilans et
présentation de comptes inexacts
lorsque j'ai repris l'enquète j'ai
compris les luttes féroces qui se sont
déroulées à l'abri des regards autour de
l'ex champion du nucléaire dans les
principaux rôles des grands patrons
comme henri proglio ex président d'edf
un secrétaire général de l'elysée claude
guéant et son mentor nicolas sarkozy
mais aussi des personnages moins connus
comme sébastien de montessus un proche
collaborateur d'anne lauvergeon pour
rôle ambigu appelant l'opération comme
on veut déstabiliser sur ou pas en tout
cas elle doit être écartée
trois ans après le début de la faire
j'ai fait de nouvelles découvertes sur
les coulisses de la chute d'areva en
tout commence bien entre le tout nouveau
président de la république et la
patronne d'areva anne lauvergeon
pierre péan est un spécialiste des
enquêtes politico financières
il connaît anne lauvergeon depuis plus
de 20 ans au début anne lauvergeon elle
est très bien vu par par nicolas sarkozy
oublié que que sarkozy lui a proposé un
poste ministériel à anne lauvergeon
j'ai interrogé l'éminence grise de
nicolas sarkozy l'ancien secrétaire
général de l'elysée claude guéant
il était aux premières loges il confirme
la proposition du président
il lui a proposé d'entrer au
gouvernement de façon précise lui a
proposé d'être ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche et l a refusée parce qu'elle
voulait être ministre de l'économie ou
des affaires étrangères donc il y avait
une relation d'estimé
c'est tout à fait certain bon et puis
cette relation s'est poursuivie enfin
c'est une personne qui a beaucoup de
talent anne lauvergeon décline la
proposition du président de la
république
il renouvelle néanmoins son mandat à la
tête du numéro un mondial du nucléaire
des mines d'uranium à l'enrichissement
jusqu'au retraitement des déchets et la
fabrication des réacteurs
l'entreprise regroupe toutes les
activités liées à l'énergie atomique
diplômé de l'école des mines
la présidente anne lauvergeon a commencé
sa carrière par la politique à 31 ans
elle est nommée conseillère à l'elysée
auprès de françois mitterrand
deux ans plus tard nouvelle promotion
à 33 ans elle occupe dans le bureau
mitoyen du président de la république
d'une place très convoitée à la fois
secrétaire général adjoint de l'élysée
et sherpa entendez représentant
personnel du chef de l'état pour la
préparation de ses sommets annuels
son parcours politique est un atout
c'est avec l'accord de la gauche et de
la droite qu'elle prend la présidence
d'areva en 2001 sur les plateaux de télé
les français découvrent un nouveau
visage bonsoir bonsoir à coulisse de
l'économie cette semaine avec une des
seules pédégère française qui plus est
s'occupe de lin bio verjon est la
première femme à la tête d'une grande
entreprise française
ce secteur c'est celui de l'énergie
nucléaire l'entreprise c'est areva anne
lauvergeon
bonsoir elle parle aux médias et joue la
transparence commercialisation aussi le
nucléaire c'est sera alors c'est un peu
moins de 9 milliards d'euros type
d'affaires qui est un groupe de leaders
mondial leader mondial du nucléaire elle
dépoussière l'image de l'atome
le député hervé mariton est un
spécialiste du nucléaire français pour
lui l'attelage areva lauvergeon alors
fière allure
il ya clairement au moment de la
création d'areva mais c'est resté ça
reste je souhaite que ça reste il ya une
fierté autour d'un atout industriel de
notre pays dans les champs de
compétitivité de la france de la fin du
xxème du début du xxième siècle il y a
assurément l'industrie nucléaire proche
de ses salariés
c'est la patronne star des années 2000
anne lauvergeon est même classé parmi
les personnalités les plus influentes du
monde
quand les magazines économiques anglo
saxons
mais derrière cette image de réussite la
santé financière d'areva se dégrade dans
les comptes
la trésorerie du groupe nucléaire font à
mesure des investissements risqués
d'anne lauvergeon
l'entreprise affiche plus de 6 milliards
de dette en 2009
dominique vignon ancien grand patron du
nucléaire français s'alarment des pertes
croissantes d'arrêt 20 on voyait
trimestre après trimestre semestre après
semestre
au fur et à mesure de la communication
financière d'arrivants qui était donnée
au grand public
on voyait l'endettement plonger chaque
chaque trimestre chaque semestre
on voyait 500 500 millions d'endettement
supplémentaire 1 milliards d'endettement
supplémentaire et c'était évident que ça
allait ça aller au casse-pipe c'était
évident l'entreprise s'est lancée dans
des politique d'acquisitions tous
azimuts de l'éolien des composants
nucléaires
un projet de nouvelle centrale le p r en
tout une dizaine de milliards
d'investissements qui ne seront jamais
rentabilisé dominique vignon n'était
plus dans les cercles du pouvoir mais il
se souvient que d'autres à l'époque ont
tiré la sonnette d'alarmé
j'ai compris que d'autres l'avaient fait
qu'ils étaient beaucoup plus en
situation de le faire proglio
proglio le président d'edf il a dit aux
pouvoirs publics
attention surveiller votre arrêt va ça
va mal se passer henri proglio c'est
l'homme qui est derrière nicolas sarkozy
lors de cette réception à l'elysée nommé
à la tête d'edf en 2009
il est un proche de l'ancien président
il lorgne sur une des pépites du groupe
d'anne lauvergeon
les réacteurs son ambition devenir le
numéro un du nucléaire français à la
place d'areva
il annonce la couleur dès novembre 2009
dans cet article des échos
mon ambition est d'avoir une filière
nucléaire française qui fonctionne
cela implique qu'on repense toute la
filière en particulier les rôles d'areva
les difficultés d'anne lauvergeon joue
en faveur du président d'edf elle fait
face à deux énorme ratage un contrat de
20 milliards d'euros
avorté avec abu dhabi est un gouffre
financier en finlande où une centrale
dernier cri c'est vrai que sur ces deux
affaires le gouvernement était très déçu
parce que c'était un enjeu national en
terme d'emploi en termes de recettes en
termes de consolidation de la filière
nucléaire qui était tout à fait
considérable pour claude guéant
il y a urgence à réformer la filière
nucléaire française
il fallait arrêter une situation dans
laquelle tout le monde faisait tout il
fallait que chacun soit remis dans son
rôle
edf compte tenu de sa taille
compte tenu de la diversité de ses
métiers compte tenu aussi de son
expérience par edf a quand même
construit 58 réacteurs en france dont
edf nous semblait présenter toutes les
garanties beaucoup plus de garanties qu
areva en tout cas entre anne lauvergeon
et henri proglio
la guerre des chefs et déclaré quand
même un truc absolument invraisemblable
vous avez deux entreprises publiques qui
sont quasiment entièrement la propriété
de l'état et qui ne se parlent plus
c'est quelque chose d'extraordinaire et
vous pouviez dire stop on arrête ce jeu
là bah écoutez j'ai en tout cas sur un
certain nombre de sujets tout fait pour
qu'ils se parlent à nouveau alors je
vais réunissait ensemble dans mon bureau
il était bien obligé de se parler et de
répondre aux questions que nous mettions
sur la table derrière l'affrontement des
ego
deux logiques économiques
d'un côté le modèle existant défendu par
anne lauvergeon les mines d'uranium
l'enrichissement les réacteurs la
construction de centrales nucléaires et
le retraitement des déchets tout le
nucléaire français sous le contrôle
d'areva
l'autre modèle consiste à démanteler
areva à edf la construction des
réacteurs et des centrales areva ne
garderai que l'enrichissement et le
retraitement des déchets
quant aux mines d'uranium elles seraient
privatisées
parmi les investisseurs pressentis
il en est un qui est très intéressé par
les mines
il s'agit du qatar cet émirat désertique
est riche de plusieurs centaines de
milliards de dollars grâce à ses
exportations de gaz
l'émir tamim al thani est un ami de
nicolas sarkozy il a été le premier chef
d'état reçu à l'elysée en 2007
un investissement qatari dans les mines
d'areva
pour anne lauvergeon c'est brad et
l'indépendance énergétique de la france
dans un communiqué publié en novembre
les représentants du personnel juge ce
projet inacceptable pour l'elysée la
patronne d'areva est devenu un problème
claude guéant songe à s'en séparer la
question s'est posée quand vers gens
très clairement affiché son refus des
positions qui étaient définis par le
gouvernement
bon c'est difficile de la part d'un
gouvernement d'accepter que patronne
d'une entreprise publique se mettre dans
cette situation à l'auberge en était un
un caillou était un obstacle à une
définition d'une nouvelle politique
nucléaire
le areva tel qu'il a été imaginé par
anne lauvergeon ne convenait plus au
nouveau meccano industriel dans l'ombre
de ces grandes manoeuvres orchestrées
depuis l'elysée anne lauvergeon va
devenir la cible d'opérations secrètes
appelons l'opération comme on veut
déstabilisation ou pas en tout cas elle
devait écarter
selon le journaliste pierre péan ces
manoeuvres vont même impliquer certains
des plus proches collaborateurs de la
patronne d'areva ce que j'ai que moi
même voir dans l' enquête c'est que les
personnes qui cherchaient à évincer à
l'auberge ont officiellement ou
officieusement avait des relais à
l'intérieur il y aurait donc chez areva
des gens qui travailleraient contre les
intérêts d'anne lauvergeon dans cette
entreprise sensible
un homme est chargé de la sécurité il
s'appelle jean michel chiron
c'est un ancien général des forces
spéciales alerté par des rumeurs qui
visent sa patronne il sollicite un
enquêteur indépendant
marc germain je le retrouve en suisse à
deux pas de la frontière française
c'est une époque où la présidente
d'areva
subissez des pressions à la fois de
l'environnement politique français et
des marchés et sa position était
fragilisée donc l'idée de jean michel
chaire hausse était de protéger la
présidente de toute pression extérieure
et c'est dans ce cadre là que des
enquêtes étaient nécessaires sur les
intentions réelles ou supposées des
collaborateurs qui auraient pu ne pas se
montrer très loyaux vis-à-vis d'elle
le détective mène son enquête il finit
par identifier le comportement intrigant
de l'un des plus proches collaborateurs
d'hannover re jean sébastien de
montessus le directeur des mines de
l'époque
le voici filmé ici à gauche en chemise
bleue aux côtés de sa présidente
c'était en 2009 lors d'un voyage de
presse en afrique
il faisait partie de sa garde rapprochée
trois ans plus tard en 2011 dans le bras
de fer qui oppose la présidente d'areva
à l'elysée sébastien de montessus joue
désormais une tout autre partition le
fruit de mes recherches assez rapidement
montré qu'il avait des accointances
auprès de conseillers de l'elysée et
qu'il s'y rendait de façon assez
régulière et que c'est visite coïncidait
avec certains événements qui participait
à la déstabilisation d'anne lauvergeon
est ce que il ya les relations entre ces
bassins ont sûrement oui sûrement
assurément assurément il y avait des
relations parce que de toute façon ne
serait-ce que techniquement si vous
voulez elle allait pas que tout passait
par claude guéant le directeur des mines
ce serait donc rendu discrètement à
l'elysée à l'insu de sa présidente anne
lauvergeon
j'interroge claude guéant mais sur ce
point précis sa mémoire est incertaine
on a eu récemment à quelques années
quand même j'ai pas une mémoire très
très précise de la façon dont ça s'est
passé une chose est certaine c'est que
j'ai eu l'occasion de parler avec
sébastien montay juge aux jeux sont plus
très bien comment il est entré dans le
cercle mettant dans dans les circuits
des rencontres l'enquêteur pierre péan
est beaucoup plus précis
montessus faisait des notes directement
à l'homme clé de la redéfinition de la
politique industrielle française à
claude guéant qui lui même la passer au
delà à l'elysée à ceux qui suivaient les
ces questions là et ça je peux amener la
preuve
enfin preuve c'est sur une forme de deux
notes que sic et que s'il le fallait je
pourrais produire et donc me l'a montré
et je pourrais vous la montrer
cette note la voici elle est à l'en tête
de sébastien de montessus elle confirme
l'existence de contacts étroits entre le
directeur des mines d'areva et le
secrétaire général de la présidence de
la république claude guéant copie des
notes échangé avec le secrétaire général
de la présidence
ce document atteste d'un plan secret
élaboré à l'elysée incluant le découpage
et la privatisation d'une partie d'areva
créer un groupe minier français tout en
facilitant le financement d'areva
sébastien de montessus pensait-il
prendre la tête de ce nouveau groupe
minier ou voulait-il sauver l'entreprise
le détective privé lui a son idée sur la
question
la loyauté de monsieur de montessus
était beaucoup plus centrée sur ses
propres intérêts que sur les intérêts de
sa présidence en 2011 après l'accident
nucléaire de fukushima
le contexte économique de l'uranium a
changé la privatisation du pôle minier
d'areva est finalement abandonnée
mais l'entreprise n'en a pas fini avec
les détectives privés et les enquêtes en
douce sans en informer sa patronne
sébastien de montessus lance une enquête
sur les conditions d'achat par areva
d'une petite société sûrs amine une
société minière acquises à prix d'or
dans des circonstances controversées
l' enquête est confiée en suisse à un
cabinet de détectives alpes service
selon ce document confidentiel parmi les
intermédiaires de la vente durera mines
visé par l' enquête apparaît incertain
olivier fric
olivier fric qu'il est autre que le mari
d'anne lauvergeon
le député marc goua auteur d'un rapport
parlementaire sur areva n'en revient
toujours pas de voir que de telles
pratiques d'espionnage ait pu exister
chez le champion du nucléaire
il n'est pas banal quand même de voir un
cabinet intervenir payée par
l'entreprise pour espionner sa président
en charge c'est quand même ça pourrait
faire l'objet d'un scénario d'un film
c'est quand même pas banal
les enquêteurs d'alp service fouilles
dans les activités et la vie privé
d'olivier fric
ces relevés d'appels téléphoniques ce
week end ses parents ils prennent même
des photos du siège de ces sociétés en
suisse
les détectives se demande si le mari
d'anne lauvergeon a profité de l'achat
du ramine par areva pour toucher de
l'argent ils découvrent qu'ils possèdent
des comptes en suisse
nos recherches nous ont par ailleurs
permis d'établir que monsieur fric est
en relation avec plusieurs fiduciaires
et banque privée suisse
ce qui pourrait laisser supposer que
monsieur fric détiendrait des actifs
cachés en suisse
lors de ma première enquête en 2014
le commanditaire de ces recherches
sébastien de montessus avait accepté de
me rencontrer
ils se défendent est d'avoir voulu
cibler le mari de sa présidente sur
l'évier fric qu avait participé d'une
façon ou d'une autre aux opérations
d'areva c'est vous qui avez commandé une
enquête générale sur l'acquisition de la
mine qu'est-ce que vous pouvez m'en dire
encore une fois je n'ai vu aucun élément
qui fasse état concernant les
différentes personnes que vous avez
mentionné de comportement absents cible
il ya des interrogations et aucun
élément qui permet de de donner une
quelconque valeur à ces différentes
allégations le 30 juin 2011
anne lauvergeon n'est pas reconduite à
la tête d'areva peu de temps après elle
dit avoir trouvé sous son paillasson
le rapport d' enquête sur son mari elle
porte plainte contre x pour espionnage
et violation de la vie privée
je suis profondément navré tout ça ça me
désole ça me consterne est ce que je
souhaite c'est qu'ils font c'est que
tout ça s'arrête
je pense que j'aurais été complices si
j'avais si je m'étais tu ici j'avais
effectivement accepté d'être complice en
me disant d'une affaire de barberousse
sébastien de montessus est finalement
relaxé
depuis cette affaire anne lauvergeon
reste persuadé que cet épisode fait
partie d'un complot pour l'évincer
d'areva en mai dernier elle dénonçait
devant les juges
une manipulation opérée dans son dos par
la direction des mines d'areva en lien
avec claude guéant le secrétaire général
de l'elysée